por por Dios Yael pueblos Colombian
defender la constitución ill alleges the
Quran on August the 7th 2018 Yvonne do
hem Marquez was sworn in as president of
Colombia his campaign promise was
straightforward to get the country in
shape and ready for a rapid development
process enough time has passed since
Yvonne do he rose to power for visual
politic to ask some questions what is
the true strategic plan of the Duke a
government that is how does he want to
transform Colombia and can he achieve
this goal what could be the legacy of
his passage through Casa novena the
Colombian White House while listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
with almost 50 million inhabitants
Columbia is the second most populous
country in South America but it is above
all a very very complicated country on
the one hand there's the problem of the
guerrillas and the drug trafficking
which happens to be one of the country's
biggest industries to give you an idea
Columbia produces no less than 70% of
all the white powder on the planet of
course as you can imagine behind this
huge business that moves billions of
dollars every year there are some
powerful criminal organizations
organizations that are willing to
control their territory come hell or
high water that's precisely why violence
rates remain so high Columbia homicides
increased in 2018 due to violence after
the FARC disarmament according to the
country's forensic Authority there were
12,000 130 homicides last year 6.7% more
than in 2017 and the violence isn't
limited to drug deals gone bad or
territorial disputes in the last three
years alone it's estimated the more than
500 community activists and leaders lost
their lives at the hands of these groups
and about 200,000 people have been
displaced from their homes and it
doesn't end there
[Music]
the LNF are leftist guerrilla group also
linked to drug trafficking continues to
operate yellin guerrilla group claims
the attack on the police academy that
caused more than 20 deaths
what's more about 3,000 former members
of FARC may have taken up their weapons
again and coca plantations are at a
record high coca crops in Colombia
reached an all-time high in 2017 171
thousand hectares
as if all of these problems weren't
enough Columbia has recently had to deal
with the arrival of hundreds of
thousands of Venezuelans fleeing Nicolas
murderers despotic regime it's estimated
that proximately 1.5 million Venezuelans
already live in Colombia one thing that
is very positive is the Colombian
Solidarity that's been witnessed the
problem is that this influx of people
also puts enormous pressure on stability
and public resources okay so let's say
that this is the downside but it's not
all bad news
in Colombia you see despite all the
continuing problems such as drug
trafficking guerrillas paramilitary
groups violence corruption the country
has actually registered an economic
growth of 3.8 percent per year over the
last 40 years the middle class has grown
in the country hasn't suffered any
hyperinflation and don't think this is
normal because it's anything but and
don't forget that we're talking about
South America in that same period Peru
Bolivia Argentina Ecuador Brazil and
Venezuela have undergone hyperinflation
at some point in time in other words we
could almost say that Colombia is a
model of stability however Colombian
President Yvan Duque doesn't quite agree
[Music]
colombian president yvonne bouquet
affirms that he isn't satisfied with the
more than three percent growth that the
Colombian economy is expected to have
this year and intends to quote push the
country to grow by more than five
percent annually yes the colombian
president has set a goal of five percent
now how will they be able to achieve
this how will they go about it it seems
complicated considering the scenario
that's been described doesn't it well
you know what we can't say if you'll be
successful or not but the important
thing is that this government has a plan
which unfortunately doesn't seem to
happen very often these days right
president Macri and it's a plan that
doesn't look too bad and which we can
summarize into three main points so
listen up
[Music]
fleeing latin-american taxation this may
come as a surprise but in general
latin-american countries tax systems
have one common characteristic and
that's that they have the highest
corporate taxes on the planet on an
example
the inability of the government to raise
money from living flesh-and-blood people
has made them tax the productive system
voraciously this is quite the opposite
of the example set by Nordic countries
and they are often held up as a
benchmark and if Latin America is
usually a disaster in this field
Colombia is the worst of the worst but
ok so something you might now be
wondering are silent I mean how much
worse could it probably be 1.2 vines
maybe well not even close
[Music]
to give you an idea according to the
latest doing business report from the
world's bank the effective tax rate on
Colombian companies that is if we
consider all the tax as a company is
obliged to pay local national labor
corporate then it turns out that
Colombian companies face an average rate
of seventy one point nine percent
seventy one point nine percent of the
company's commercial profit and is the
difference between income and expenses
without taking taxes into account goes
directly into the public administrations
pockets to give you an idea when a
Colombian company buys a machine v80
cannot be fully deducted for that
purchase and companies have to pay taxes
even if they are losing money it's all
pretty crazy then obviously all of this
does have consequences such high taxes
on the productive sector affect the
Colombian economy's ability to be
competitive and on top of this we have
to add the exhausting and tedious
bureaucracy that is so typical of Latin
American countries basically under these
conditions it would be easier to win a
fight against in his prime Floyd
Mayweather than it would be to start a
business that works so surely now you
might understand why Latin American
countries generally have low investment
levels low export levels and a lot of
informal economies Latin America's
informal economy surpasses that of
sub-saharan Africa of the first time
[Music]
in fact it's estimated that more than
54% of Colombian companies aren't
operating within official guidelines and
of course an informal economy can't
access large contracts it can't get bank
financing and it doesn't have legal
security which often means they just
can't grow while addressing the
situation is precisely the first major
point of due case plan in facts at the
end of last year he got his Congress of
the Republic of Colombia to approve a
comprehensive tax reform his tax reform
basically the reform aims to reduce the
tax requirements of Colombian companies
by slightly increasing taxes on personal
income for example on people who earn
more than a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year and who currently pay low
taxes the reform will also increase v80
collection so with the new reform
corporate income tax will be
progressively reduced from thirty three
to thirty percent some additional taxes
will disappear and a simplified single
tax system with very low rates will be
created to encourage the formalization
and growth of small businesses and
that's not all in addition the reform
has also created tax incentives for
entrepreneurs for investments in large
projects investments in the tourism
sector and in the so called orange
economy and yes okay this may seem
controversial after all why applying to
some sectors and not others but at least
it seems to be a step in the right
direction the problem and perhaps what
has made this project so controversial
is that duque is going to increase
public spending significantly and the
government already has a very high
public deficit so even though the
measure means a reduction of taxes in
the medium term the truth is that in the
short term it implies increasing them
that is what other reductions are
progressive and will be applied
gradually the increases will be applied
from the very beginning for example
there's going to be a temporary
surcharge on bank profits and this well
it hasn't been popular but still and you
know the non visual politic we don't
like tax increases at all we think the
change is a step in the right direction
Latin America in general in Colombia in
particular have to treat the productive
sectors better Latin America needs more
companies not more taxes unfortunately
this reform has been declared
unconstitutional due to a formality now
the government has to get it approved
again by Congress so could president de
Kate get it through
[Music]
the orange economy the second key points
in Yvonne Dukas strategy is to promote
the so-called orange economy with fiscal
incentives participate or loans venture
capital and startup accelerators now
let's pause a second many of you
especially those who are Colombian what
we want during what what on earth is the
orange economy well no it's got nothing
to do with fruit it's an umbrella term
for creative activities that are related
to intellectual property music design
audio-visual productions YouTube
channels architecture art software
design etc sale sale for she attends a
todos nuevos and Prada Mentos in as
industrial scrappy was a technological
maybe you've noticed that more and more
movies are being filmed in Colombia even
more productions from platforms such as
Netflix or Amazon Prime are being made
in this country and there's a good
reason for this in 2012
lor one five five six was passed which
provides significant tax breaks and aid
to produce and shoot films and
television series in Colombia that way
they not only sought to grow the
national film industry but also to
foster a better image of the country
around the world this resulted in a
soaring number of productions that were
shot in Colombia well now Ivonne Duque
wants to do the same with all the
activities that make up this orange
economy and pay attention because this
is serious business today Colombia's
orange economy is almost three times
larger than the coffee industry and
almost as big as the entire mining
sector we're talking about economic
activities whose worldwide trade rose at
annual rates of 7% and whose value in
2015 exceeded five hundred billion
dollars the orange economy is larger
than new oil oil reserves are limited
but creativity is unlimited we have to
know that the most important heritage we
have in a society is the talent of its
people Yvonne Duke a well in order to
boost other orange economy activities
the government is implementing
participatory financing plans venture
capital initiatives entrepreneurship
centers and tax exemptions so will it
work will the orange economy or really
be able to transform Colombia well only
time will tell
but you know what the plan it
sound pretty good and the plan is
different in that it is linked to human
capital and not just natural resources
or large companies that have
suspiciously close ties to governments
which unfortunately is a bit of the norm
in Latin America but it doesn't end
there we still have a third essential
pillar in this strategy
[Music]
the new bets
it isn't strictly avant do k's idea but
it looks like the new government has
accepted it
Columbia wants to become a big player in
the world's market for medical cannabis
this is a sector that is quite literally
growing like weeds and is expected to
become a market of almost 50 billion
dollars by 2025 and Columbia intends to
have a slice of that pie more than 40%
of it we're talking about a huge sector
and a considerable boost for the
Colombian economy especially for the
economy in the poorest rural areas it
calls us to the possibility of being
very important worldwide players in
terms of exports estimates state that we
could effectively reach levels of six
billion dollars u.s. annually in exports
south bonita vice minister of business
development
so along with pointy green weeds the
government's other big gamble consists
of promoting fracking to increase oil
production so far four pilot projects
have been approved that could produce
more than 400,000 barrels per day when
fully operational this would mean
increasing Colombia's oil production by
almost 50 percent
[Music]
in conclusion with all these measures
with greater investments in
infrastructure and education
Ivan Duke his government plans to
achieve its objective of raising
Columbia's economic growth to above 5%
so will they achieve it well here on
digital politic we'll be watching
closely but as thing stands doesn't look
too bad of course there are other issues
yet to resolve which could generate self
reports for example the sharp increase
in public spending or the constant
devaluation of the Colombian peso and of
course Duke A's government has unlimited
itself to act only in the economic
fields about drug traffickers how can
they improve security what are they
doing in terms of foreign policy
well we'll cover these topics in an
upcoming video here on this channel so I
really do hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also please do check
out our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast you provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also if this
channel is possible because of patreon
and our patrons on that platform please
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]